hallo hallo wir sind im urlaub in
santorini und ich habe mir gedacht ich
brauche jetzt einfach mal ich wollte
eigentlich ab und europa kann vielleicht
über in stories machen und jetzt hab ich
mir überlegt kommt ich nehme es jetzt
auch am ende probiere ich hoffe dass es
schmeckt und das rezept schreibt euch
dann natürlich auch die mengenangaben in
die video beschreibung ich sehe jetzt
einfach mal los rezeptors von der
griechen wir machen den orangen kuchen
post carlotta das ist ein ganz ganz
bekannter griechischer orangen kuchen
westhofen es schmeckt ich hab nämlich
auch überhaupt keine almosen erwartet
ich probiere es aus ohne kamera man also
haben wir natürlich da aber ich wollte
jetzt nicht ich wollte dem zelt
kameramann leben gekommen das ist urlaub
ich bin jetzt einfach mal ganz oldschool
auf sowie youtube auch eigentlich ist
einfach mit dem handy frei schnauze
hauptbestandteile sind natürlich orangen
dann habe ich hier viel teig der ist
auch relativ wichtig ja und alles andere
sind erst standard zutaten also zucker
backpulver so typisch griechisch der
freund wird sagen die linke jetzt
einfach mal los für die er fast sagen
griechische küche redet der türkischen
extrem daher waren wir jetzt was kein
zucker sehr hoch da verliebt wie jetzt
in griechenland nicht wasser aus der
leitung sondern hier darum uns und unser
wasser her
diesmal sorgen sagt habich wasser im
topf brauchen wir noch den sagt eine
orange erste hälfte ist schon mal gut
aus gepressten orangensaft flecken so
und jetzt kommt er sagt mit zum wasser
das man reingehen ist ganz typisch
griechisch sind ich glaube es ist auch
erst im winter ist er war ich hab's auch
in einer theke gesehen hier mitten im
sommer deshalb ist auch kein problem ein
bisschen zu und jetzt ganz richtig
zucker und der nachkochen heißt ganze
zum zucker sirup
falls euch über hintergrundgeräusche
wundert haben sein während meine
aufnahme gerade diese milchschnitten
packungen so richtig nerven dort
aufgemacht und schmeckt die griechische
besser als die deutsche
aber und hier kocht gerade mein zucker
so auch ich werde ihn glaube ich so drei
minuten ankommen lassen damit er auch so
ein bisschen ein diktat niemals schalte
ich den herrn aus dass er sich jetzt
erstmal abkühlen ist nämlich wichtig
dass er gleich abgekühlt auf den warmen
kuchen kommende zuckersirup wie kann man
bitte grapefruit stadt orangen kaufen ja
ein schild auf dem schnitt stand orange
nur noch richtig hätte auch geld stinkt
nicht kenntlich griechisch lesen was ist
los
[Musik]
ich weiß ja nicht auch in die
schweißtropfen sehen könnt aber das war
ziemlich anstrengend
jetzt habe ich hier meine grapefruitsaft
da kommen jetzt dazu die griechen nehmen
olivenöl beim backen hat seinem süßen
backen habe ich zwar greife ich auf
sonnenblumenöl zurück und dann kommt
auch noch ein bisschen zum 2 1 ein
bisschen backpulver und zucker und
vanille extrakt der extrakt in
griechenland seit mal mit einfach mit
dem käfer gefunden haben sonst mehr
ausgebuddelt elf aus gebundenem
ausgefüllt ausgibt bestücken
ach und was nicht fehlen darf ist
natürlich griechischer joghurt es
versteht sich ein griechisches bisher
komme ich jetzt ist der urlaub hier ist
jeder urlaub schön was macht jetzt da
ist es natürlich dienen die einbindung
der konsistent ist also vegan kriege ich
dieses rezept habe ich mich in zürich
den joghurt dazu zehnprozentigen habe
ich genommen
griechischer joghurt küche hier gut geht
torsten teichert aber das ist schon was
habe ich denn die reste hauses ist ja
eine verschwendung oder entstellt mir
doch jetzt kommt das gute teil drauf hat
so guten riecher european nicht
verschwinden sehr schadet ja genau das
will ich sehen wie viele sind 180 gramm
sein kommt schon hin ich bin super
gespannt diakonie ohne war
jetzt einen spickzettel test rezept dem
ich mal griechen nicht mehr alles
erklärt ja mittlerweile musste aber ganz
schön erfahren sein weil waage braucht
eigentlich nicht mag ist hier hier drin
im kopf in der hand das nonplusultra
jetzt habe ich hier backpulver und dann
kommt auch backpulver und ca 2 zugleich
werde die zuletzt ein bisschen
reduzieren zuckersirup jean bart nicht
reingemacht
also jetzt hier so reicht auch schon und
jetzt verhören
du kommst noch wissen wir weltweit ein
tun damit mir bisschen werbung haben ein
bisschen werben dafür nicht zu kurz
kommen müssen dazu seien ultra stolz
weil ich finde das ist auch so ein
bisschen ist ein geschenk charakter
sieht er sowieso schaust du hast kannst
du nicht du bist und du bist doch ein
foto soweit ich das nie da ja kauft ja
gerne lange hin und her überlegt wie wir
das machen sollen unser aber grafikkarte
tausend mal alles verändern musste
größte genau weiß was ich lustig findet
was angefangen alleine aufgenommen was
jetzt nicht
jetzt bin ich doch wieder da
[Musik]
ja ich bin's vorbei es reicht jetzt ich
könnte so helfen
ok vorher ist ein urlaub soll also nicht
nur dass wir das hier großstadt
koranischen haben es ist auch bei diesem
rezept wichtig es muss nur einen tag
vorher machen ja was ich gemacht habe
man muss diesen free dort trocknen
lassen
das heißt er muss trocknen damit ihr so
fröhlich wir in besonderer mission zum
beispiel oder im backofen kann man
vielleicht beschleunigen und schafft den
sommerlook spät und dann sehen uns
welche wieder dafür dass wir dann bald
viele trocknet schnell aus über die
finanzen zum trocknen einfach liegen und
dann dem ausgleich wieder wunderschön
bröselig wird das ganze zwar
beschleunigt leute 100 grad zehn minuten
der viele taxis schön sind ja ganz schön
brechen
und der kommt jetzt gebrochen in den
teig rein getrocknet getrocknet und
jetzt verrühren wir alles schon so
gespannt werden das kommt mir schon sehr
viel vor aber das muss so sein
doch das sieht gut aus
jetzt habe ich die masse hier mal in so
eine auflaufform getan sprechers noch
ein bisschen kommt meine hände vor dem
peloton
weil er mit seiner stärke immer
ausgelegt ist
dort kommt jetzt in den backofen und so
habe ich den schon vorne als 180 grad
ober grundsätzlich denke mal ich kenne
den backofen ich habe ich gehe mal so
von 40 minuten aus so fuhren ist 180
grad dem man so gut 40 minuten auch ich
kenne den ofen ich gucke auch noch mal
nach 45 minuten
und ich stehe die bildmotive raus mich
ein bisschen abkühlen weil an einem ofen
im sommer in griechenland schon heftig
sollte sich abkühlen
wenn ich heute dass du so gut ja war
heute echt müssen 1000 frühstück am 1
sie hoben ein sonnenbrand seite zu sehen
so 41 minuten nicht werten jetzt raus
holen weil ich habe das gefühl dass der
fertig ist hab ich noch die stäbchen
probe mit einem messer machen vor sich
so gut wie sie herzhaft ganz so normal
[Musik]
das sieht aus wie lasagne aber es riecht
richtig lecker hier
ob da noch irgendwie doch das gerade ist
und jetzt muss ja sofort mit dem kalten
bzw sehr lauwarm sirup also organischen
zuckersirup übergossen wer das ist der
beste part leute richtig geil ich glaube
der zuckersucht er schwimmt jetzt hier
an der oberfläche
wir können jetzt nicht probieren er muss
richtig schön runterkommt entweder heute
abend zurück sind wie ihr fand ich
richtig drauf nach oder morgen das
schwimmt der zucker sirup
aber ich habe hoffnung oder es verheißt
ich habe hoffnung dass der komplett
eingezogen wird und dem geben wir jetzt
einfach mal ein paar stunden
der soll komplett auskühlen und danach
durch ihn sogar noch in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
es wird verkostet ich habe den kuchen
noch extra jetzt gemacht weil jetzt sind
auch hamas bruder und sein freund hier
auch mit drohnen an die drohne mieterin
und so können wir auch alle probieren
dann wird auch nichts verschwendet und
damit der rest vorangehen nachbarn hier
abgegeben aber kaum fitness marke hier
die orangen nach oben drauf los bestimmt
und die augen gespannt sieht schon sieht
er sieht im ballack- doppelkurve
ähnlichen mit zwei fußballer
eigentlich hab gar keine vorstellung wie
das schmeckt säuerlich okay was sagt ihr
zu früh fertig sein
wir schmeißen euch nicht raus
schnell folgen dieser galaxie ich hätte
wahrscheinlich ähnlich
ich finde den auch richtig lecker ist
wirklich einfacher machen also wieder
mal was anderes drin ist und auch zu
winter also rezept ist auf jeden fall
nach macht tauglich du kannst du das
machen so dass ich nicht mehr wirklich
so dass ich meine was ich machen muss
also nicht so extrem solltet ihr das ist
echt dass ich öfter videos in diesem
format mache schreibt man hier und da
unten rein dann kann ich das
zwischendurch mal machen ja ich dachte
ich muss aber sagen qualitativ besitzen
nichts im vergleich zu meinen videos vor
allem deshalb weil die kamera das ist
einfach nur mein handy mit einem
mikrofon und ich schneide auch das video
schon mal gespannt wenig schnitt findet
unter last noch jeden fall einen
kommentar
und dann kosten abo und dann sind wir
uns leer gefuttert der lage vortag
[Musik]